I'm a tourist not at areas but I'm
Muslim just praise Fletcher we're all
packed and ready heading to London and
sha Allah
yeah you know we're in the UK they drive
on the right gonna go meet her brother
right now who's been a strong support
and I've known him for Wow subhanallah
almost I'm all around 10 years but it's
the first time we're gonna meet in
person
and there he goes faster brother Sonali
cool oh that's true brother I'm telling
you uh how long has it been 10 2006
movement and it's longer but never in
person never in person so I'll go ahead
from Islamic to right yeah
guys gotta check that out salami to
com.com what can they find on their just
videos yeah this is the man behind the
scenes alright so we are where we at
right now what is this this is a Ealing
Ealing this is Ealing so this is called
Ealing we're an Ealing
so the Dean show it reached you here in
the UK many moons ago yeah
mashallah all right what's your name
Holly so if you guys need the sim and
other things stop here this is West
London Apple repair Ealing look at the
London buses how guys we don't have this
back in the States look at that nice bus
that's a two-story look at that nice
two-story bus all right look at this
guy's some real food huh real food look
at this this is what I lost one thought
I was talking about pie a bad time the
real food look you see any ingredients
on this huh
no no ingredients look at no labels huh
but hopefully it's not spray I heard
Monsanto they're not really famous
popular over here huh they're not huh
but some people say cheese so which was
more appropriate Cheers thank you s'more
propia thank you yeah okay because
what's more appropriate Cheers or thank
you
I think cheese is more friendly uh-huh
like you like talking to one of your
mates yeah maybe in a pub yeah and they
yeah but I say they say even like as a
thank you I think it's a bit more okay
you guys get into cheers thank you
lesson how's that alright good thank you
Cheers we say Salaam alaikum
yeah I heard that one yeah yeah peace be
with you
now what this is the founder ground
underground see people use the trains
here more because of all the congestion
the traffic ok so now we're in Victoria
this is East London this is central
London central London we're in central
London yeah for a cup of tea the cup
that's at the Buckingham Palace yeah
they got us on the list to get in we're
gonna have to knock knock
so I guess we're here at the Buckingham
Palace
this is it right yep
okay guys we're gonna have to leave you
out here you going through here yeah
there you have it Buckingham Palace for
the Queen's oh look you got my initials
er
this is Downing Street
Mays offices like when was the waiting
work was the crowd waiting of course for
yourself what results my name is Eddie
I'm visiting from America again
I'm the leader of the Conservative Party
I'm visiting I'm a tourist not at areas
but I'm Muslim okay yeah I'm ready nice
to meet you from America what's your
name Eunice
where're you from Swedish nice to meet
you thank you thank you this is I have a
TV show called the diva show like yeah
I'm gonna give you my car did you check
it out
you ever met a Muslim yeah yeah or or
just on the news yeah well you got a new
friend
I can check me out yeah sure okay buddy
thank you monomers fair big fat right
there the millennium wheel in London
central London right and behind you you
could see a bit of the block of Big Bend
and you see the big bang clock and this
is Parliament there yeah that's the
Parliament but yeah one thing about this
millennium wheel is that what I can tell
you look it's going real slow right and
imagine that being like the the circle
of life that you know life for many of
us is going much faster but this is
going Isis slow but at the end they can
even go slower but eventually it's going
to stop all right you're gonna have to
get off
so you crate that to life eventually the
ride of life is gonna come come come
come but we don't know we know here when
is gonna stop
but eventually life will come to an end
boom and then you got to figure out what
have I done with my time what have I
done with my time allocated here in this
dunya think about that